After writing 5,000 lines of code,
I'm finally done.
>> Hey Walter,
salami baguettes for lunch.
Is that your game that
you've been working on?
>> Yeah.
Let's grab some lunch and
I'll show you the game afterwards.
>> Awesome.
[MUSIC]
Yeah, I mean it doesn't pretend
to be anything that it's not.
It's salami on baguette, it's awesome.
>> That's amazing.
>> So, let me show you this
game that I've been working on.
I think you're going to like it.
>> Awesome.
>> Wait, hold on a second.
[SOUND] It's crashing.
I promise you this was
working about 30 minutes ago.
It doesn't even look like any
lines of code have changed.
What!
[SOUND]
>> Well, that was a frustrating
situation.
And this was just a personal project.
But imagine if this had happened while
working on important code at work.
Luckily, these types of
situations can be easily avoided
using something known
as version control.
In this lesson, you'll learn to use Git,
a popular distributed version control
tool to track changes and switch
between different versions of the code.